et le premier invité du 7 8 ce soir sur
ce plateau en direct entre le 18 19h
c'est Patrice Henri Duchenne rebonsoir à
vous invitez du 7 8 président du réseau
automobilité et véhicule d'Île-de-France
qui œuvre je le disais en début
d'émission pour la filière automobile
pour son avenir un avenir difficile on
va commenter déjà les derniers chiffres
au niveau du mois d'août moins 11,4%
c'est la chute enregistrée dans
l'immatriculation des véhicules neufs
juste sur le mois d'août par rapport à
la même période l'an dernier il y a
c'est un chiffre presque historique on
est passé sous la barre des cent mille
véhicules immatriculés en un mois
c'était pas arrivé depuis 1997 oui on a
de on a de mauvais chiffres aujourd'hui
sur le marché français qui touche
l'ensemble des des constructeurs y
compris les importateurs qui sont
diverssement touchés on sait
qu'aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre de
pays d'Europe du Sud le marché
automobile ralenti en même temps il faut
relativiser les choses on terminera
l'année avec une baisse en France qui
devrait être autour de de 10 12% et
on a heureusement d'autres marchés dans
le monde qui permettent de compenser au
moins partiellement les baisses que l'on
peut connaître aujourd'hui sur le marché
européen qui a marché comme on le sait
saturé et toucher par la crise
économique alors forcément vous occupez
de l'Île-de-France mais le réseau peut
pas s'occuper uniquement des
constructeurs sur un bassin donné c'est
l'ensemble de la France qui est touché
même au-delà dans ce domaine de
l'automobile mais quel est tout de même
la situation des grands groupes comme
Peugeot Citroën ou encore Renault qui
sont implantés directement là en
Île-de-France dans les Yvelines il y a
deux aspects on sait que l'Île-de-France
à cette particularité d'être à la fois
un grand centre pour la production
d'automobile mais également la première
région pour tout ce qui est Recherche et
Développement Innovation puisqu'on a sur
le territoire à Guyancourt bien
évidemment le technocentre de Renault et
à Vélizy ainsi qu'à la Garenne des
grands centres de recherche pour le PSA
Peugeot Citroën à côté de ça on a
d'autres sociétés d'ingénierie qui sont
les partenaires pour l'innovation des
grands constructeurs et des grands le
président est venu chez Valeo également
dans cette région récemment donc ça je
dirais l'innovation et la recherche vous
avez des variations à la marche qui sont
liées à la crise mais cette activité-là
elle ne ralentit pas elle n'aura elle
ralentit d'autant moins que l'innovation
la recherche le développement de
nouveaux produits le développement de
nouvelles technologies c'est la
condition pour assurer je dirais
l'avenir à la pérennité de cette filière
donc de ce côté-là il y aura pas de de
de mouvement majeur ça veut dire qu'en
Île-de-France même dans le département
des Yvelines mais dans toutes les villes
de France globalement puisque c'est le
cadre d'intervention du ravi il y a
suffisamment d'innovations de nouveautés
qui permettent d'éviter de s'inquiéter
pour l'emploi par exemple
alors est-ce qu'il faut avoir des
inquises je dirais l'innovation elle
prépare l'avenir de la filière alors sur
l'emploi aujourd'hui on peut gérer
remarquable par la forte densité alors
vous l'avez vu récemment Citroën annoncé
effectivement un plan de départ qui lui
par exemple ne touche pas les personnels
de production ils touchent plutôt les
services administratifs aujourd'hui vous
avez un certain nombre de départs qui
sont programmés
sur le site de Vélizy mais c'est là
encore des des départs qui sont d'abord
que des départs volontaires et qui
représente je dirais une toute petite
minorité des effectifs qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement importants
puisque tant à Guyancourt cavalisé on
compte aujourd'hui plus de 10000
techniciens et ingénieurs juste une
petite parenthèse on a vu quelques
images du salon de l'automobile de la
précédente édition la prochaine ce sera
la fin du mois de septembre est-ce que
c'est un événement qui peut permettre de
booster de relancer un petit peu c'est à
dire que dans un contexte où on sait
qu'en France on a un certain climat
d'autophobie pas toujours
justifiée le salon et l'occasion je
dirais de montrer les superbes produits
qui sont les fruits de cette industrie
et notamment les produit fabriqué en
France et les produits dés constructeurs
français et il faut dire que cette année
ce sera d'autant plus remarquable que on
aura la DS3 cabriolet fabriqué à Poissy
la 208 avec cette toute dernière version
GTI XY fabriquée à Poissy nous aurons la
Clio 4 fabriqué à Flins la Zoé premier
véhicule électrique de grande diffusion
fabriqué à Flins donc je pense que le
département et la région sont très bien
représentés à ce Mondial achetez-vous
encore des voitures neuves c'est la
question que nous sommes allés vous
poser aujourd'hui on l'a vu les chiffres
ne sont pas spécifiquement bons sur le
mois d'août moins 11,4%
d'immatriculation par rapport à l'an
dernier et sur la même période mais vous
achetez-vous des voitures neuves et
sinon pourquoi expliquez-nous je préfère
le neuf tout simplement parce que c'est
une première main donc c'est mieux
mais à l'occasion c'est vraiment si
voilà on a une un modèle qui nous
intéresse vraiment je prendrai
l'occasion si vraiment c'est un problème
on va dire budgétaire plutôt mais sinon
du neuf c'est toujours de préférence non
occasion je préfère parce que voiture
neuve je peux enfin je préfère les
voitures anciennes pas une nouvelle
voiture il y a trop de technologie et
c'est plus cher d'ailleurs à du neuf au
moins j'ai une garantie obligatoire et
puis bah au moins on a on sait que c'est
un véhicule qui n'a pas été conduit par
d'autres personnes avant alors je vais
plutôt sur l'occasion
parce que savoir c'est moins cher et
les plus récentes possibles voilà le 9
la première année on perd pratiquement
déjà 30% donc alors du neuf parce que je
suis sûr qu'elle n'a pas été conduite
par des par des gens qui ne l'auraient
mal entretenu d'occasion pour le prix
trop cher neuf d'occasion parce que je
suis pas assez riche pour m'en acheter
une neuf
j'ai acheté ma voiture neuve pourquoi
parce que pour pas avoir de soucis parce
que je suis une femme
les Français les françaises restent
attachés au véhicule enfin tout de même
on sent qu'ils ont envie d'acheter des
véhicules neuves c'est la part la part
relative des véhicules neufs et
d'occasion est assez constante dans
notre pays puisque ça fait je dirais une
bonne dizaine d'années qu'il se vend en
gros qui a deux tranches de virgules 5
transactions de véhicules d'occasion
pour une transaction de véhicule neuf
votre réseau leur avis regroupe les
grands groupes justement et les plus
petites entreprises aussi mais comment
vous intervenez au quotidien quels sont
les missions et les projets que vous
pouvez porter pour aider cette filière
autant le ravis à deux missions
essentielles c'est favoriser les
mutualisations c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans
un contexte de compétitivité accrue on
sait que la compétitivité de plus en
plus difficile sur un marché mondialisé
très ouvert aujourd'hui notamment les
PME mais même les grands groupes ont
tout intérêt à mutualiser entre eux
qui peut l'être alors quand on partage
le même territoire je dirais qu'on a
d'autant plus de facilité à trouver à
réfléchir ensemble sur les choses qui
peuvent être mutualisées ce soit de
l'innovation que ce soit de l'export que
ce soit du partage de siège sociaux et
la première mission du ravier est donc
d'aider ces entreprises à mettre en
commun un certain nombre de choses on
l'a fait beaucoup pour ce qui est des
ressources humaines mais je vous propose
des images de Flins de Renault Flins de
l'usine Flins et lorsqu'on sait que les
batteries électriques par exemple sont
pas réalisés sur flan par exemple pour
pour Renault ça veut dire que vous
n'avez pas pu intervenir vous n'avez pas
assez de poids ah non alors là on
intervient pas dans la stratégie
notamment la stratégie du constructeurs
alors place on intervient à la demande
des entreprises sur des questions sur
lesquelles nous demandent d'organiser
des choses en matière de sauce humaine
on a mis en place il y a déjà 6 ans
un tronc de formation commun pour les
opérateurs et pour les personnels de
logistique typiquement ça c'est une une
solution beaucoup de PME nous
sollicitent pour les aider à mettre en
commun un certain nombre d'avancées
technologiques on est en train de
travailler beaucoup aujourd'hui sur la
sécurité de fonctionnement des véhicules
électriques sur des architectures
destinés aux petits véhicules
électriques puisqu'on a un certain
nombre de PME du département qui ont
d'ailleurs été
remarqués par le Conseil Général qui
développe aujourd'hui des projets de
petits véhicules électriques très
innovants aujourd'hui vous nous dites il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude particulière à
avoir donc département de fermeture de
sites à Flins par exemple non non non
Flins et sur deux véhicules aujourd'hui
qui se lancent donc de nouveautés donc
de ce côté-là
le leur état à l'optimisme voici va
récupérer on le sait un certain nombre
de fabrication d'Aulnay aujourd'hui les
sites industriels ont intérêt à un je
dirais saturer les capacités de
production existantes qui est la
condition sinequanone pour continuer à
travailler de manière rentable et le
site de Poissy aujourd'hui est également
à l'honneur puisqu'il lance 208 qui est
un véhicule qui a été lancé au printemps
et la DS3 les nouvelles versions DS3
notamment
les sous-traitants sont directement liés
à l'activité des usines je prends le
fabricant de sièges lits qui est en
région Île-de-France qui est Yvelines
qui est dans le Val-d'Oise il était déjà
à partir de son usine le centre qui
approvisionnait Aulnay et Poissy donc
les volumes restent les mêmes la
fermeture d'aulnaine va pas avoir de
conséquences sur le volume global en
l'occurrence de berline C3 qui seront
produite en région Île de France Patrice
Henri Duchenne vous restez avec nous
nous avons reparlé tout à l'heure
également automobile avec Dominique
mocard le fondateur d'ADN concept une
société yvelinoise qui a travaillé avec
Renault autour de la Twizy il a permis à
ce véhicule toute électrique d'être
disponible en autopartage sur le système
de de Vélib' en quelque sorte vous
pourrez nous livrer le regard sur le
parcours de cette entrepreneur yvinois
pour l'instant Johanna Soudry va nous
rejoindre pour le rendez-vous culture du
mercredi juste après ce reportage
consacré aux Portes Ouvertes du Central
Fred de vigne à Voisins le bretonneux en
avant-goût des traditionnels forum des
associations
une cuisine flambe en neuve au centre
Alfred de Vigny pour mieux accueillir
les futurs élèves de l'atelier cuisine
c'est l'une des nouveautés de la rentrée
du centre de loisirs vicinois qui compte
2000 adhérents
les trois on pouvait plus circuler et
c'est vrai que la communication entre
participants aux ateliers étaient très
difficiles on va travailler les produits
de saison ça c'est assez important les
épices tout ce qui est goût saveurs etc
et on va faire un tour de France de
toutes les cuisines que l'on a
régionales et aussi européenne et
mondial s'il le faut j'aime beaucoup
cuisiner et puis je connais le chef déjà
j'ai choisi l'option une fois par mois
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des cours le matin
et puis après on partage le repas on
mange tous ensemble voilà j'ai choisi
cette option là et puis on fait un peu
de tout de la cuisine régionale cette
année le Centre propose 51 activités
contre 47 l'an passé parmi les
nouveautés peinture chinoises champs
prénatale et plus inattendu dans un lieu
dédié aux loisirs un atelier
d'accompagnement pour trouver un emploi
c'est l'association Solidarité nouvelle
face au chômage qui intervient ici au
centre donc c'est un peu atypique dans
un centre culturel ça permet de d'avoir
un accueil supplémentaire de tout ce qui
existe aussi actuellement pareil des
bénévoles qui aident qui soutiennent
c'est un coaching prochaine occasion
pour rencontrer les professeurs et
s'inscrire le forum des associations de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui se tiendra le
8 septembre au gymnase des pyramides